now the prime minister and the
chancellor have written a joint article
in the newspaper this morning declaring
the rise in national insurance uh has to
go ahead you have said you don't like it
but um
have you lost the battle
well i agree with the government that we
need the money for the national health
service and social care there's an
umbilical cord between the british
people and the nhs and they want that
money spent i also agree that we
shouldn't borrow to pay for this because
all that does is defer tax rises and
also puts pressure on interest rates
what i'm just asking the government to
do is to go back to the drawing board
and look at how they raise that money
and i've suggested that the government
looks at windfall taxes on big business
particularly oil companies for example
who've been breaking it in over the past
a couple of years perhaps increase
capital gains tax
as well so we can raise those funds for
the nhs without hitting um low
income workers
this is very interesting i mean um
if if i didn't know that you're a
conservative mp i would have uh
assumed that that was a labour mp
speaking because that is precisely what
the labour party says it wants to do and
precisely what the prime minister and
the chancellor said that they would
never do
well i don't think the labour party of
proposed windfall taxes on oil but what
um if you go back to margaret thank you
sat there rachel reeves stood and talked
to me and said exactly those words well
if you well if you that far that's fine
but if you go back to margaret thatcher
and you were talking about mrs thatcher
earlier she imposed windfall taxes on
the oil industry she put taxes on banks
because they needed to raise uh money in
extraordinary circumstances we face
emergency circumstances now because of
the
rise huge rise in energy bills up to two
thousand pounds we've got petrol and
diesel nearly reaching one pound fifty
at the pumps we've got inflation over
five percent so families are facing a
real struggle uh to feed uh all their
that with you know their families and uh
pay their cloak pay for the cost of
clothing and the cost of living is is is
a huge problem at the moment
you can understand mr alvin why i'm
slightly disconcerted this this morning
i i have um the foreign secretary coming
in and telling me
after she has for many years been seen
as a tax cutting uh thatcherite uh uh
member of parliament you know the
pictures on tanks and all of that
telling me oh well sorry got to put up
taxes and now you're telling me what the
government that you support which is
actually in government and has
the ability to do this should really
implement a labor program
i don't accept as a labour program i'm
i'm a practical conservative as i said
mrs thatcher imposed windfall taxes on
the oil industry and put taxes on banks
to raise uh vital funds that were needed
during the
1980s and if i have a choice between
taxing low-income workers so if you're a
worker on 20 000 pounds you're going to
be paying an extra 90 pounds if you're a
worker on 30 000 pounds you have to pay
an extra 214 pounds with this tax that's
a huge amount of money especially with
costs in energy going up in petrol and
diesel and food and and everything else
so a much better option in my view would
be a win for tax on a big business so to
pay for that that would pay for the nhs
money that is that is needed without
hitting low-income workers
all right well look i mean
let's let's suppose that the chancellor
um
decided that what he'd written this
morning was wrong having listened to on
this program
that would be an extraordinary blow to
his authority not to mention the prime
minister's were he now to change his
mind
uh you can't possibly expect that to
happen can you
well the chancellor and the prime
minister set out their view
in the newspapers this morning i
understand that it is a very difficult
financial situation all i can do as a
back bench mp represent my constituents
in harlow is try and campaign to cut the
cost of living because as i've mentioned
they are struggling to
feed their families and
i get emails every day from uh people
who cannot afford their energy bills as
it is they're
going to go up potentially to 2 000
pounds a year that's going to be
unaffordable and we've got another pot
of money the government have cut
overseas aid that's a separate argument
that people will make whether it was the
right or wrong decision but that has
raised 4 billion pounds we should use
that 4 billion pounds to cut taxes or
cut the 80 for the lower paid
let's talk a bit about the politics of
this um let's suppose that the
tax rise does go ahead how seriously do
you think that
will affect the conservatives uh
electoral support do you think that's
really going that will be an issue
well of course people are struggling
with the cost of living so if they can't
afford to pay their bills they're hardly
going to be
very positive towards the government so
it depends uh what the government does
in other measures to try and mitigate
against that we're told we're going to
have a cost of living package
in february i hope very much that
that takes place and i'll look forward
to see what the government is proposing
but it has to be urgent action because
people are struggling as i say to pay
their bills
uh the other aspect of what the public
may be thinking about in relation to
politics this uh this weekend and you
may have heard this from your
constituents
uh is of course uh what various people
in government and in whitehall did
during covet you actually as i
understand it had to shield
at various points during the pandemic
how do you feel looking at those
pictures hearing the account of those
parties and knowing what you had to do
about what was going on in government
while you were shielding
well yes because i have um brought
myself will pause in other problems i
did have to shield but my positions
harlow many people across the country
had it much worse off than me and they
suffered terribly by not being able to
see their
relatives uh or or people you know sadly
passing away and not being able to see
their loved ones as they were
dying so we all feel um hugely let down
by what has
gone on it shouldn't have happened i had
constituents talking to me about it only
yesterday in harlow how upset they were
as to what had happened in downing
street and what i've called for is for
three hours from the
uh prime minister for him to respond to
the
anguish of the public to take
responsibility for what has happened and
to reset the government and focus on the
genuine people's priorities like uh what
we've just been talking about robert
robert is there a four are possibly
there which is resign
i'm not agitating against the promise
i'm certainly not putting a no
confidence motion for two reasons first
of all i don't think the public would
welcome bloodletting or change of
government in the midst of a crisis in
terms of eastern europe in terms of uh
the economy and the cost of living
coming out of kobe and secondly i do
accept that i owe the prime minister
some residual loyalty not just for
winning the 2019 election and for brexit
but also for the vaccine program for the
jobs miracle we've got
in our country and uh i think those are
important things to
to to remember but that doesn't mean as
i say i don't want uh the pr i want the
prime minister to take responsibility to
reset the government and respond
properly to the public